[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct je suis ravie de vous retrouver
au sommaire ce soir la grande question
de cette rentrée quel est le sens du
travail alors où les députés débattent
des nouvelles règles d'indemnisation du
chômage pour inciter à la reprise
d'emploi le sujet et partout ça a
l'airbar recrutement difficile grande
démission et même droit revendiquer à la
paresse comment comprendre cette perte
de sens le pari présidentiel du plein
emploi est-il tenable grand débat à
suivre avec nos invités dans un instant
mouvement de révolte ou début de
révolution notre grand témoin ce soir va
nous aider à comprendre ce qui se joue
en Iran depuis trois semaines depuis la
mort violente de Macha mini 22 ans pour
une mèche de cheveux qui dépassait trop
de son voile la colère de faiblit pas
dans le pays elle sait quand même
au-delà de la jeune génération nous en
parlerons avec la sociologue
franco-iranienne asadéchian dans la
deuxième partie enfin trois affranchis
ce soir trois parties pris la pertes
blanches de Léa chamboncelle cessons de
vouloir contrôler le corps des femmes
j'aurais mis Baudot pour la politique
les féministes vont-elles créer leur
propre partie politique après les
affaires Bayou et catenens qui secouent
à gauche et puis l'économie avec Fanny
guinotcher réformer les droits de
succession la promesse du candidat
Macron divise la majorité voilà pour le
menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
le travail prend-il trop de place dans
nos vies bonsoir à tous Depuis la
pandémie le monde du travail est en
pleine mutation crise de sens démission
en chaîne conflit éthiques le refus de
travailler dans beaucoup de secteurs se
multiplient malgré des hausses de
salaire on va essayer d'y voir un peu
plus clair c'est d'ailleurs dans ce
contexte que les députés examinent le
projet de loi sur les nouvelles
conditions d'indemnisation du chômage on
va en parler dans le détail ce soir
bonsoir Benoît sert vous êtes un peu aux
premières loges de ces questions de
recrutement et de changement dans le
rapport que les Français ont au travail
vous êtes le DRH de L'Oréal France et
surtout vous présidez l'Association
nationale des DRH bonsoir Coralie Perez
et bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
socio-économiste ingénieur de recherche
à l'Université parisien et vous venez de
publier cet essai redonner du sens au
travail c'est au seuil coécrit avec
l'économiste Thomas coutreau sous-titres
une aspiration révolutionnaire ça mérite
une explication soit Boris Vallot et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes le
président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale député PS des
Landes votre collègue de la majorité
Paul midi député renaissance de
l'Essonne va nous rejoindre dans un tout
petit instant avant de se pencher sur la
réforme de l'assurance chômage on va
s'arrêter sur ces mutations justement
avec vous Stéphane le grand
bouleversement les Français et le
travail si j'ai bien compris Stéphane
Lacoste
[Musique]
et bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes
bonsoir à tous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir alors si j'ai bien compris Myriam
il y a de plus en plus de Français qui
se disent que quand même le boulot c'est
pas le cas de plus important dans la vie
hier je vais d'ailleurs lu un chiffre
assez frappant dans le Figaro regardez
il y a 30 ans donc dans les années 90
60% des Français disaient avec le
travail c'est très important dans la vie
et aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus que 24%
donc je me suis passé ce log mais ça
fait un peu mouvement de fond quand même
cette histoire alors est-ce qu'il faut
en déduire que le droit à la paresse de
Sandrine Rousseau réclamé je vous parle
sociologie vous ramenez tout à la
politique c'est votre passion je le sais
alors c'est vrai que vous faites
référence
un petit différent qui a eu lieu à
gauche sur la question du travail donc
c'était Fabien Roussel qui a la fête de
l'humain a dit le travail c'est une
valeur de gauche mais ouvre investir
dans la production plutôt que dans les
allocations et alors sans surprise
Sandrine Rousseau qui est donc elle
aussi est de la nups a dit exactement
vraiment le contraire on l'écoute moi je
vous dis qu'on a un droit à l'appareil
je vous dis qu'on a un droit à la
transition de des métiers c'est à dire
que quand on a un métier dans une
industrie polluante et bien on a le
droit à changer on a le droit aussi de
faire des pauses dans sa vie et surtout
il nous faut retrouver du temps le sens
du partage et la semaine de quatre jours
que là on n'est pas du tout là-dedans on
est dans la valeur travail mais la
valeur travail pardon mais c'est quand
même une valeur de droite et alors
histoire de vraiment bien savoir la
bonne ambiance qui règne à la lupesse je
vous propose d'écouter la réponse de
Fabien Roussel à la réponse de son vrai
nom ça montre qu'on a des différences de
vue sur ce sujet il y a ceux qui
défendent le droit à la paresse il y a
ceux qui défendent l'idée de mettre le
RSA à 1000 euros et bien je défends moi
l'idée que nous devons garantir nous
devons nous projeter dans une société
qui garantit sa douce un vrai emploi
alors on va laisser nos invités dans un
instant tranché la querelle mais c'est
vrai qu'en France la relation au travail
change depuis la pandémie et pas qu'en
France j'imagine que tout le monde a
entendu parler du bigweet évidemment
je vous le dis en français le Big quick
la grande démission ce mouvement qui a
eu lieu l'an dernier aux États-Unis on
estime qu'à 38 millions d'Américains 38
millions j'insiste
beaucoup plus grosse ampleur qui ont
quitté leur emploi donc forcément quand
on marche souvent les pâtes américains
la presse française s'interroge est-ce
que la grande démission va toucher la
France est-ce que puisque les Français
trouvent que c'est pas si important que
ça le travail ils vont profiter de la
vie et laisser tomber le boulot et alors
est-ce que ça pourrait arriver alors je
me suis renseigné dans les pages
économiques et apparemment non c'est pas
exactement ce qui est en train d'arriver
donc je vais vous montrer deux courbes
pour illustrer ça celle de gauche donc
c'est la progression des démissions en
France les voyez qu'on a pas tout à fait
un record mais un chiffre très élevé
depuis justement le covid donc on se dit
les gens démissionne oui mais c'est pas
pour autant qu'ils arrêtent de
travailler parce que quand on regarde en
revanche le taux d'emploi bah lui aussi
ne cesse de grimper donc il est même un
encore qui n'ont pas été atteints puis
2004 donc on peut arrêter de travailler
mais pas forcément enfin on peut
démissionner plutôt mais pas forcément
pour arrêter de travailler ça peut être
la manière par exemple de d'aller
proposer ses services à une autre
entreprise et qui va vous payer plus
cher c'est aussi une manière de faire
jouer la concurrence quand il y a une
pénurie de recrutement d'ailleurs on le
voit dans les témoignages les
recrutements
ou changer et notamment chez les plus
jeunes alors là j'imagine que la vie de
Benoît sert d'où vient l'enfer enfin
j'imagine oui elle était déjà mais enfin
avant le covid quand les gens arrivaient
devant vous de votre bureau ils étaient
dans leur petit soulier et maintenant
que j'ai l'impression qu'après le covid
ils mettent les pieds sur le bureau
carrément ils sont prêts à fixer leurs
conditions alors en plus je dis pas ça
parce que je suis vieux mais j'ai
l'impression que c'était quand même pas
mal les jeunes qui se sont montés le
bourrichon avec cette histoire de covid
non regardez en tout cas il a un sur
deux qui est prêt à refuser un emploi si
il n'a pas droit au télétravail alors
que moi bon seigneur évidemment hein je
vais pas faire le difficile je suis bien
content d'avoir une petite place au
chaud le télétravail pour ce que vous
faites c'est compliqué comment on fait
alors pour recruter les jeunes alors la
bonne nouvelle c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour Benoît je pense c'est que c'est
super fastoche de recruter des jeunes
pour savoir comment faire on leur
demande qu'est-ce qui est le plus
important pour vous et il leur répond
ils le disent regardez ah non c'est pas
le télétravail c'est pas l'environnement
c'est pas non pas la flexibilité c'est
là
rémunération donc c'est très simple si
vous voulez embaucher des jeunes il
suffit de bien les payer voilà ma pierre
au débat mais tout le monde sera pas
forcément d'accord merci beaucoup pour
ce regard le débat et poser Coralie
Perez vous vous dites dans votre livre
c'est vachement intéressant parce que
cette perte de sens elle va au-delà des
conditions de travail on en a beaucoup
parlé sur ce sur ce plateau dans le
privé dans le public manque de
reconnaissance manque de rémunération
pénibilité mais il y a une perte de sang
qui va au-delà de ces conditions-là
alors pour nous le sens du travail c'est
une des dimensions des conditions de
travail alors je vais peut-être
commencer par définir ce qu'on appelle
le sens du travail donc pour nous un
travail qui a du sens donc il y a trois
dimensions il faut que le travailleur et
le sentiment d'être utile socialement la
deuxième condition c'est qu'il puisse
travailler en cohérence avec ses valeurs
morales et professionnelles faire du bon
travail selon ses normes
professionnelles et enfin qu'il est ce
qu'on appelle une capacité de
développement c'est à dire qu'il puisse
mettre dans le travail ses compétences
ses sa créativité donc on voit bien que
sur ces dimensions la question de
l'organisation du travail et absolument
cruciale puisque c'est elle qui va
offrir ou non
aux travailleurs les conditions en fait
du sens au travail donc cette perte de
sang est causée par l'organisation du
travail à la beaucoup changé qu'est-ce
qui est pointé du doigt alors nous ce
qu'on met en évidence à partir des
enquêtes conditions de travail c'est
qu'il y a des environnements dans
lesquels les travailleurs trouvent moins
de sens que les autres donc ce sont les
grandes entreprises à caractéristiques
socio-démographie et de postes
équivalentes les grandes entreprises
celles qui sont enfin ont des objectifs
chiffrés qui qui de rentabilité voilà
qui évalue le travail
effectivement on pointe du doigt la
gouvernance actionnariale le travail qui
est fragmenté codifié standardisé qui
laisse peu d'autonomie
travailleurs ont pointe également du
doigt et on montre en pyriquement que ça
a un effet sur le sens au travail les
restructurations les changements
organisationnels auxquels sont soumis
très régulièrement les travailleurs et
qui leur fait perdre de vue finalement
les finalités de leur travail d'un
néoïsme digital qui accélère le
processus je rappelle que vous avez
travaillé sur des données dans cet essai
d'avant la crise covid qui a servi au
fond d'accélérateur à ce que vous avez
observé alors effectivement les données
qu'on utilise sont les données de
l'enquête conditions de travail 2013 et
2016 on mettait on met donc en évidence
avant même la crise sanitaire que le
fait de trouver peu de sens à son
travail encore une fois à
caractéristique de poste et
socio-démographie
identiques conduit à une probabilité
plus importante de quitter
volontairement son emploi et ce facteur
perd de sens et même plus important que
le sentiment d'être mal Ré donc la crise
sanitaire a certainement amplifié encore
une fois l'attention portée aux
conditions de travail et
particulièrement au sens du travail
alors et d'ailleurs urgent pour vous de
s'interroger sur le contenu et les
finalités de nos activités
professionnelles et vous trouvez
d'ailleurs clairement que les politiques
ne se saisissent pas suffisamment de ce
sujet Benoît sert et je viens vers vous
juste après alors le recruteur qu'est-ce
qui change qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit je
partage pas mal des points qui ont été
évoqués le premier temps que la crise
elle a rien créé tout accéléré et que ce
que vous avez décrit notamment les
évolutions d'orientation du travail le
moins hiérarchique ces éléments là on
les connaît depuis des années seulement
beaucoup d'entreprises n'avaient pas la
pression nécessaire pour changer les
choses et la crise est venue donner
aux salariés deux éléments le premier
élément c'est que une organisation du
travail qu'on avait vendu ou qu'on
croyait quelquefois sincèrement
d'ailleurs commisable depuis des années
finalement de l'était pas puisque le
conf moi montrer qu'on peut travailler
différemment donc les gens aujourd'hui
disent bah puisque dans l'urgence vous
avez su bouger pourquoi vous bougez pas
dans la société ça c'est une première
tendance et la deuxième chose auquel moi
je suis très attaché et je j'ai pas mal
de travailler ou échanger sur le sujet
que je partage le trajet je le traduirai
pas tout à fait comme vous c'est que je
trouve c'est un peu je vais faire vous
connaissez je vais faire un petit peu
choquant mais sauf qu'on s'est beaucoup
intéressé à la qualité de vie au travail
et pas assez ce que vous avez décrit
dans votre manière à la qualité du
travail c'est à dire que moi je le vois
des collaborateurs qui ont les
compétences pour bien faire comprennent
ou alors place dans la chaîne de valeur
autrement dit comprennent que leur style
font est indispensable à ce qui se passe
en amont et indispensable à ce qui se
passe en aval et qui sont reconnus comme
cela à ce moment là les sujets que vous
avez évoqués un peu disparaissent parce
que ça donne le sentiment qu'ils ont une
utilité pas que sociale mais économique
non seulement dans la société mais
également dans l'entreprise elle-même et
c'est pour ça que
il y a un effort à faire parce qu'on à
force de travailler sur la cuvette qui a
été vidé au travail on a oublié la
qualité du travail et le dernier point
on sait que la désaffection pour les
grandes entreprises elle est pas récente
et je pense qu'il y a un lien entre les
deux c'est à dire l'entreprise sont des
espèces de grosses machines qui sont
perçues quelquefois comme assez
déshumanisante et à ce moment-là les
gens disent finalement comme je sais pas
bien ouf je me trouve dans la chaîne de
valeur donc je suis remplaçable etant
remplaçable c'est pas gênant si je m'en
vais donc ça espèce de système après il
y a plein d'autres raisons qui évoquent
et qui explique qu'on est confronté à
une place du travail qui n'est pas moins
forte ou plus forte mais qui est
différente dans la tête des gens il
donne pas au travail le même rôle qu'il
ne donnait il y a peut-être 10 ans et
encore moins il y a 20 c'est plus un
rôle d'émancipation je pense que
c'est plus un refonctionnel
c'est sans doute mieux que moi mais je
serais pas surpris que moi je vois je
rencontre plein de jeunes que je vous
présenter maintenant pas mal de fac etc
c'est intéressant de voir qui
globalement ils disent arrêtez de vous
occuper de ma vie par contre donnez moi
un cadre d'organisation du travail qui
me permet de choisir ma vie alors
qu'avant on avait un peu tendance à dire
l'entreprise
en fait c'est une question de j'ai deux
champs sur lequel je suis engagé sur
l'un comme sur l'autre aucun des deux ne
doit déséquilibrer l'autre mais la perte
de sens vous vous y retrouvez pas
forcément non pas plus que cela bonsoir
Paul midi et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes députés renaissant de de l'Essonne
on va venir sur la réforme parce que
c'est une façon d'y répondre aussi à ces
questions de recrutement compliqué vous
diriez qu'il faut redonner du sens au
travail comment un politique peut
répondre à cette question là on a vu
Roussel Rousseau j'imagine que vous êtes
plus Roussel que Rousseau mais au-delà
oui je pense que c'est important de
donner de plus en plus de sens et moi
avant d'être député j'étais entrepreneur
c'était ça ma carrière donc j'ai
embauché des centaines et des centaines
de personnes et j'ai embauché beaucoup
de jeunes puisque moi j'ai créé des
startups dans le e-commerce donc j'avais
beaucoup de salariés c'est très jeune et
donc cette vague de demande de sens je
l'ai vu au quotidien dans mon travail de
patron
un projet il faut que ce projet ait du
sens s'il a pas de sens ou qu'il est pas
en cohérence avec leur valeur mais ils
ont pas envie de se lever le matin pour
ça moi je trouve ça normal parce que
nous notre vision du travail ça doit
être une émancipation ça doit te donner
un sens à la vie on veut se dépasser par
le travail et donc ça me paraît tout à
fait cohérent et moi en tant à l'époque
que patron évidemment je mettais voilà
beaucoup d'énergie à définir une vision
définir des projets donner du sens créer
aussi des emplois qui ont du sens dans
l'entreprise pour que d'abord pour être
encaissé de recruter des talents voilà
et c'est important tous les emplois
n'ont pas forcément de sens en tout cas
même si vous dites bien dans votre essai
que ça n'est pas une question au fond de
de classes sociales et de de comment
dire de diplôme et d'emploi très
qualifiés il y a des emplois vous le
montrez bien dans votre essai qui ont
énormément de sens aux yeux de ceux qui
les occupent et qui peuvent être plutôt
au bas de l'échelle notamment les
professions du Caire les assistantes
maternelles les aides soignantes les
aides à domicile et effectivement des
professions qui nécessitent peu diplômes
et qui ont en commun voilà de prendre
soin des autres et pour autant ce sont
des professions qui font face à des
conflits éthiques puisque le travail
peut être aussi très rationalisée avec
des des contraintes temporelles très
fortes donc on peut avoir finalement un
fort sentiment d'utilité sociale en
termes de finalité mais pour autant des
conditions de travail et d'organisation
du travail qui ne permettent pas de
trouver du sens
révolutionnaires écrivez vous vous dites
même ce qu'on est en train de vivre
c'est une forme de révolution vous
utilisez le terme dans votre essai Boris
Vallaud qu'est-ce qui peut faire le
politique face à ça d'abord défendre et
c'est comme ça que nous le formulons le
travail digne est porteur de sens et
j'étais assez heureux de voir le travail
qui est très documenté qui qui a été
fait pour j'allais dire mettre une forme
de de réalité des scientifiques à ce qui
était une intuition digne c'est la
rémunération la rémunération c'est pas
accessoire il y a beaucoup de gens qui
ne vivent pas de leur travail pour
lequel les fins de mois c'est pas le
temps c'est le 15 alors on voit que dans
la restauration notamment là où c'est
compliqué de recruter il y a des
évolutions bien sûr bien sûr et
heureusement mais la réalité objective
c'est que depuis 2008 le salaire des 10%
de Français les plus riches augmentaient
trois fois plus vite que celui 10% de
français les plus les plus modestes que
en un an le salaire des patrons du CAC
40 était multiplié par deux et que
évidemment il y a un problème de
partageur donc vous militez pour une
augmentation du Smic
la dignité c'est le salaire c'est aussi
les conditions de travail et puis
porteur de sens c'est je trouve que la
diffusion que vous en avez donnée à mon
avis elle est même cumulatives dans les
trois éléments que vous avez donné me
paraît tout à fait juste et quand je
vois des métiers qui sont des métiers de
j'allais dire de
passion infirmières
professeur voire qu'il y a des pertes de
sens alors que le sentiment de l'utilité
est complet et bien on voit bien que on
a des choses à régler et tout ce
déballage sur le sens du travail sur le
rapport au travail des nouvelles
générations en réalité le préalable il
devrait être préalable à toute espèce de
réflexion sur la réforme du marché sur
la réforme beaucoup mais c'est une
valeur moi je dis que vous une valeur de
gauche il y a pas de valeur travail son
travail de valeur voilà non mais c'est
important de lire c'est la valeur du
travail quand vous vous abîmez au
travail que vous perdez du sens que vous
souffrez sur le plan
psycho-organisationnel je comprends
qu'il y a des gens qui est un peu de mal
alors elle est où la formule en tout cas
elle me dit et puis ensuite on avance
sur la réforme nous avec la majorité
présidentielle on se bat pour le plein
emploi donc on se bat d'ailleurs plus
pour le droit à l'emploi que le droit à
la paresse pourquoi on se bat pour le
plein emploi parce que justement c'est
ça qui va changer le système dans le
plein emploi c'est le salarié qui
choisit son entreprise et qui est donc
dans capacité d'être dans l'émancipation
de savoir le sens qui veulent trouver
dans quel organisation quelle entreprise
et c'est un une situation qui est
totalement différente que celle que je
que j'ai connue moi depuis que je suis
né dans ce pays où je suis né dans un
pays avec un chômage de masse quand il y
a un chômage de masse vous avez beaucoup
moins de choix donc vous n'êtes pas en
capacité de choisir votre vie c'est pour
ça aussi en raison pour laquelle on veut
se battre pour le piano c'est l'objectif
une réforme pour tenter d'y parvenir
celle de l'assurance chômage pour
inciter les chômeurs à retrouver plus
vite un emploi et répondre aux
difficultés de recrutement le texte est
en fait le prolongement de la réforme
précédente appliquée en 2021 alors que
va-t-il changer précisément les détails
Stéphanie DESPER
adaptez le système de l'assurance
chômage à la situation économique c'est
ce que veut le gouvernement qui cherche
notamment à combler les pénuries de main
d'oeuvre inciter les actifs à retrouver
un emploi plus rapidement plus
rapidement qu'aujourd'hui alors que de
nombreuses opportunités existent ce
n'est pas jeté le propre sur eux ça
n'est pas les culpabiliser ou un légué
que certains profitent du système il
nous faut donc renforcer le retour à
l'emploi rapide lorsque les opportunités
de l'emploi sont très dynamiques et en
revanche quand il y a moins d'emplois il
est nécessaire que ces règles deviennent
plus protectrices en clair quand les
offres d'emploi sont rares le régime
d'assurance chômage serait généreux à
l'inverse quand les emplois pourvoir
sont nombreux les conditions
d'indemnisation seraient plus strictes
tous les syndicats sans exception sont
contre d'après eux en réduisant la durée
d'indemnisation ce système aggraverait
la précarité au lieu d'avoir par exemple
24 mois
on va avoir que 18 mois bon bah tous
ceux qui auront trouvé du boulot avant
au bout de 6 mois ou un an eux sachant
rien changé mais tous ceux qui ont été
les plus en difficulté et qui sont juste
avant au chômage de longue durée ils
vont basculer au RSA 6 mois plus tôt
autre piste moduler les allocations
selon les régions si vous habitez dans
un bassin d'emploi ou le chômage est
faible l'accès à l'assurance chômage
sera plus compliqué et inversement
inconcevable pour les syndicats rond
l'égalité entre les demandeurs d'emploi
au niveau du territoire national et ça
c'est pas possible pour nous on doit
être traité à égalité qu'on soit
demandeur d'emploi à Lille ou à
Marseille à Paris ou à Rennes rien n'est
tranché les députés ont seulement acté
le principe de la modulation les
critères précis eux seront définis par
des discussions entre partenaires
sociaux et gouvernement la réforme doit
entrer en vigueur début 2023 Paul Mehdi
est-ce qu'on peut être dans une forme de
vérité statistique quand on dit que les
indemnités chômage dans notre système
actuel dissuade la reprise d'emploi
parce que c'est un petit peu la
philosophie de la philosophie pour être
très clair nous ce qu'on veut faire
c'est adapter un centre de règles de
l'assurance chômage et de dire que quand
l'emploi va bien ses règles sont plus
incitatives mais quand l'emploi va moins
bien c'est vrai que sont plus généreuses
et on ne veut pas toucher au niveau
d'indemnisation
par exemple à la durée d'indemnisation
pourquoi parce qu'on voit qu'il y a une
corrélation très forte entre la durée
d'indemnisation et la durée de retour à
l'emploi il existe pas de situation très
concrètes ou toucher le chômage c'est
plus avantageux que travailler je vous
pose un peu brutalement comme ça mais
quand on écoute le rapporteur qui est
dans l'hémicycle en ce moment même
marque Ferracci il dit par exemple la
permittence ce qui organise un travail
irrégulier en ont continué dans le
système actuel en plus des locations
dommage que ceux qui sont dans un dans
un travail tous les jours bien sûr
quelques cas qui existent ils ont été
limités par la dernière réforme de 2019
ils sont limités par exemple par la
prime d'activité qui a été d'ailleurs
augmenté cet été dans le paquet pouvoir
d'achat donc il y a encore quelques
possibilités d'être dans ce cas là mais
c'est pas du tout la masse de la
situation de la science chômage le sujet
c'est de pouvoir moduler en fonction de
la situation de l'emploi la durée
d'indemnisation et quand il y a beaucoup
d'emplois disponibles et bien de
proposer une durée d'admination qui est
plus courte et on voit que quand elle
est plus courte la durée de retour à
l'emploi est plus courte les études
montrent très clairement que c'est à la
fin de la période d'indemnisation très
souvent que le chômeur retrouve un
travail ou en tout cas se met en
recherche et donc cette fin de
perception des indemnités elle est
fondamentale dans un contexte où il y a
de l'emploi c'est le bon sens cette
réforme
que nous ne savons pas ce que nous
votons puisque en réalité ce sera par
décret que les règles seront fixées
c'est-à-dire qu'on dit signe un chèque
en blanc on verra après d'évidence et
vous avez des raisons d'inciter le
rapporteur il y a l'idée que plus les
indemnités seront perçus de façon courte
et plus elles sont bases puisque la
dernière réforme qui était la première
depuis 1971 adopté contre les
partenaires sociaux a fait baisser en
moyenne les allocations de 17% de baisse
d'indemnités
et probablement parce que ça ça n'a pas
été démenti les conditions pour
recharger ses droits donc la réalité
c'est que en effet par rapport
aujourd'hui il pourrait y avoir contenu
des différences de mode de calcul pour
se recharger des droits la possibilité
que que ça baisse ça il y a rien qui le
dit puisque ce n'est pas ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas dans la loi ensuite il faut
quand même dire que vous avez
60% des chômeurs qui sont pas indemnisés
vous avez parmi ceux qui peuvent
prétendre allocations chômage 30% de nos
recours le rapport la très tardivement
de d'évaluation que nous avions demandé
il y a il y a quelques nécessaires pour
percevoir
cela il n'abuse de rien ils sont en
recherche de travail et puis vous avez
une offre d'emploi aujourd'hui
pour 8 demandeurs 8 demandeurs d'emploi
en fait probablement que d'une certaine
manière nous sommes déjà dans une forme
alors le chômage diminue quand même et
il y a 300000 emplois
ont manifestement Paul bidi puis ensuite
nous indiquer excusez-moi je pense que
c'est un rapport qui est incorrect parce
que vous comptez à la fois les chiffres
de la DARES qui sous-estiment largement
le nombre de postes vacants puisqu'ils
pas en compte la fonction publique les
entreprises de moins de 10 salariés et
toutes les entreprises comme les miennes
par exemple à l'époque qui déclarait pas
à l'adresse les postes étaient vacants
donc vous sous-estimez très fortement le
300 000 et de l'autre côté vous comptez
l'ensemble des chômeurs mais l'objectif
c'est d'aller au plein emploi le plein
emploi c'est par 0 % de chômage c'est
50% de chômage parce que il y aura
toujours du chômage
et le nombre de
qualité qui sont attends partiel faut
mettre en rapport aussi avec ce qu'est
aujourd'hui marché mon travail ça va
retourner à l'emploi des des gens qui
vont avoir des mini Jobs c'est un des
jobs précaires dégradés comme en
Allemagne la réalité l'Allemagne
d'ailleurs vous avez vu revient en
arrière c'était légal en France donc
vous avez en France nous avons en France
un tiers des CDD de moins d'un mois de
toute l'Europe 30 % des CDD sont de
moins d'une journée quand on parle de
perte de sens et de dignité au travail
il y a évidemment ça et cette régulation
du marché du travail je crois que si on
ne se pose pas la question de la
régulation du marché du travail des
grandes mutations que nous avons
affronter de comment on gère les
transitions professionnelles comment on
articule ces périodes d'activité
inactivité les temps de vie et ben en
fait on est sur une réforme qui est
idéologique et qui en fait le dernier
avatar au fond de Leclerc
je pense que nos téléspectateurs l'ont
bien compris l'oeil du terrain parce que
elle a pas été évaluée en fait cette
première réforme sur l'assurance chômage
elle est en application depuis 2021
est-ce que on connaît ses effets
difficile de le calculer pour une raison
très simple c'est que la reprise
économique est très forte et par
conséquent et la fossé le jeu par
rapport à ce qu'on connaissait donc des
éléments de comparaison sont pas
vraiment mais sur le fond de la réforme
moi je vais pas rentrer dans le débat je
laisse les petites le faire je dis
simplement que je crois que ça pose deux
victimes sur le fond peut comprendre la
logique on sait qu'elle existe au Canada
pourquoi pas mais d'abord le marché du
travail canadien français souvent rien à
voir ni dans la réglementation j'essaie
donc il faut faire attention comparaison
comme par exemple c'est pareil que pour
la grande démission ça existe pas en
France pour les mêmes raisons d'ailleurs
en revanche ce qui est ennuyeux et moi
j'en ai échangé avec le milieu du
travail donc j'ai pas de problème ce qui
est ennuyeux c'est que le marché du
travail n'est pas monolithique
autrement dit vous avez des fonctions
qui sont rares et qui effectivement il
n'est pas normal je vous suis votre
raisonnement que des gens qui détiennent
les conférences et fonctions n'aillent
par l'emploi parce qu'il y a des emplois
qui correspondent à ce qu'ils font mais
le problème c'est que vous avez des
d'autres fonctions qui en revanche ne
connaissent pas ça et je trouve que le
risque c'est que oui on va sans doute
réduire une partie du sujet mais vous
avez des tas de gens qui finalement ont
des métiers ou des compétences qui ne
correspondent de toute façon pas aux
offres d'emploi qui sont faites et donc
je termine parce que j'ai un deuxième
point la deuxième chose c'est que
évidemment il faut accompagner ça avec
une manière de transférer les
compétences des gens là pour leur
permettre d'accès marché du travail qui
est nouveau on peut pas parler de
transformation du travail ils sont pas
les nouveaux métiers et la deuxième
chose où je moi j'ai pas les critères
après tout je suis pas invité à voter
dessus mais peut-être que vous les aurez
un jour c'est l'affaire des seniors
pourquoi je dis qu'en France on sait on
est un très mauvais élève on a près de
40% des gens qui arrivent à la retraite
qui ne sont pas en emploi ou moins ils
arrivent j'ai entendu avec plaisir ce
que la NRH vous le savez a beaucoup
poussé depuis 2018 en disant une réforme
des retraites sans un plan seniors c'est
un marché de dupe et on le dit donc tant
mieux on a vu que première ministre
avait affirmé donc on fait on n'a pas de
problème seulement sur la Réformation
chômage si il n'y a pas dispositif
spécifique pour les seniors alors on va
aggraver la situation parce que la
raison pour laquelle et je me mets
dedans comme une entreprise même si
comme vous savez L'Oréal a pris la tête
d'un mouvement avec 50 entreprises pour
les seniors mais le sujet c'est que ces
gens-là quand ils ont 58 59 packs 45 ça
veut dire peut-être ne retrouve pas
beaucoup de mal à retrouver un emploi
mais savent pas bien les embaucher donc
s'ils sont touchés par ça donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut que dans les critères et
l'application il va falloir protéger ces
gens là parce que là pour le coup ça
sera la double peine pour eux on attend
avec intérêt le plan senior voilà quand
même avoir le regard de la sociologue
que vous êtes Coralie Perez juste
quelques chiffres pour être indemnisés
pendant deux ans il faut avoir travaillé
deux ans en France ces quatre en Italie
8 en Espagne et 36 au Pays-Bas notre
système est plus généreux non pas sur
les montants mais sur la durée notamment
les conditions d'accès que nos voisins
européens alors normalement la durée
d'indemnisation elle sert aussi à
prendre le temps précisément de trouver
un emploi qui correspond à ses
compétences un emploi qu'on va détenir
longtemps enfin dans lequel on peut
espérer rester si l'idée c'est de
remettre en emploi très rapidement des
personnes qui de toute façon seront
insatisfaites et quand la conjoncture
repartira quitteront ses emplois je ne
voilà je ne vois pas le gain à long
terme donc j'aimerais revenir quand même
sur les raisons des tensions sur les
marchés du travail effectivement selon
les secteurs les raisons sont
différentes ce que mettent souvent en
avant les employeurs c'est la pénurie de
travailleurs qualifiés de qualification
néanmoins quand même ce qu'on observe
c'est que les secteurs que quittent les
salariés des secteurs dont les
employeurs eux-mêmes disent que qu'ils
offrent en fait de pauvres conditions de
travail des conditions de travail
difficiles des horaires imprévisibles
enfin voilà des conditions de
rémunération basse donc il y a sans
doute l'un un effort à faire pour
attirer les salariés vers ces emplois à
faire aussi sur les compensations les
aides autour l'aide à la garde d'enfants
la question de la mobilité ça le
gouvernement et on l'a entendu Olivier
du sable va faire des gestes pour
accompagner cette réforme suffisant ou
pas pour terminer
comme je ne connais ni le contenu de la
réforme ni les gestes qui pourraient
être fait vous voyez c'est ça le
problème de de la façon dont on
travaille qui est très insatisfaisante
c'est que nous ne savons pas bien ce que
nous ce que nous le décret qui va
expliquer les critères de modulation
sera pris plus tard tous ces critères
vont être définis par les partenaires
sociaux et ça c'est important de le dire
oui oui
ce sont les partenaires sociaux qui pour
définir ces critères et c'est bien
normal
je suis en chômage ils ont été mis
devant le fait accompli puisque le
gouvernement a décidé seul de cette
réforme la première fois depuis 71 on
peut pas d'un côté prétendre défendre le
paritarisme et le dialogue social et de
l'autre en réalité faire exactement
l'inverse alors ce que je constate là il
y a une nécessité pardon mais de se
poser la question sur cette relation de
vraiment les partenaires sociaux l'ont
proposé qu'on commence d'abord par une
grande réflexion sur notre rapport au
travail sur notre organisation et là
nous commençons
deux jours de discussion le débat va se
poursuivre vendredi pour un vote
solennelle vous êtes confiant d'un mot
les républicains voteront le texte
écoutez demandez-leur
j'espère que le plus de groupes et de
députés parmi les oppositions
raisonnables voteront ce texte et je
vous encourage elle n'est pas la droite
que la droite
merci infiniment merci d'être venu sur
le plateau LCP pour ce débat on va
accueillir jusqu'à présent notre grand
témoin elle est franco-iranienne elle a
vécu la révolution de 1979 elle est
sociologue et elle regarde avec espoir
mais aussi avec angoisse le soulèvement
des Iraniens qui ne faiblit pas depuis
trois semaines malgré la répression
violente du régime démolas
dans un instant pour nous aider à
comprendre ce qui se joue dans son pays
juste après l'invitation signée Marion
Becker
[Musique]
si on vous invite asadékia c'est parce
qu'on voudrait comprendre cette révolte
en Iran elle a député il y a trois
semaines déjà le 17 septembre lors des
funérailles de Massa à mini
Massa mini 22 ans cette jeune iranienne
est en train de devenir un symbole
arrêté à téhérant le 13 septembre par la
police des mœurs parce qu'elle portait
mal son voile elle meurt trois jours
plus tard à l'hôpital après être tombé
dans le coma dans les locaux de la
police
persuadé que Massa mini est morte suite
à des violences policières et en signe
de solidarité des dizaines de femmes
iraniennes ont décidé de se couper les
cheveux sur les réseaux sociaux
depuis la colère est descendue dans la
rue au risque de leur vie les Iraniennes
enlèvent et brûlent leur voix en signe
de protestation attéhéran puis dans tout
le pays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous suivez de près cette révolte
franco-iranienne vous avez vous-même
manifesté lors de la révolution de 1979
pour renverser le chat
désormais professeur de sociologie à
l'Université de Paris Cité vous êtes
l'Autriche de femmes et pouvoir en Islam
comment ASA dechyan expliquait ce
soulèvement des iraniennes la
propagation de ce mouvement féministe
malgré la répression qui a déjà fait des
dizaines de morts et plus de 1200
interpellations
[Musique]
depuis les hommes se sont joints à cette
révolte comme les footballeurs de
l'équipe nationale un soulèvement devenu
intergénérationnel au cri de femmes vie
et liberté et il s'étend à tous les
groupes sociaux désormais les Iraniens
manifestent contre le régime pour la
liberté et contre l'islam politique
les images font le tour des réseaux
sociaux malgré l'accès restreint
Internet les étudiants se mobilisent
dans toutes les universités du pays et
même dans des collèges et des lycées ces
iraniens demandent un changement radical
un État démocratique laïque alors on
vous pose la question à Ziane cette
révolte iranienne qui prend de l'ampleur
peut-elle basculer en révolution et
faire tomber le régime des mots là
bonsoir et merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation avant
d'entendre la sociologue que vous êtes
j'aimerais entendre la femme iranienne
que vous êtes vous avez évidemment des
liens amicaux familiaux dans le pays
comment d'abord comment vous vivez ce
mouvement qu'est-ce que vous vous
ressentez est-ce que c'est de la fierté
est-ce que c'est de la colère est-ce que
c'est de la peur aussi écoutez c'est la
fierté
c'est vraiment
alors je suis en même temps très
inquiète comme beaucoup d'Iraniens la
mienne pour ces jeunes qui s'y courageux
qui apprennent les rues au risque de se
faire tuer mais en même temps je suis
vraiment j'ai beaucoup d'espoir j'ai
beaucoup d'espoir parce que c'est du
jeûne et cela on peut on peut plus les
soumettre même si on les réprime même si
le régime réprime et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que pour la première
fois on le voit les femmes sont les
initiatrices à un moment social qui
s'étend comme ça a été dit à l'ensemble
des groupes sociaux il y a beaucoup de
jeunes
issus des classes populaires partout
dans le aussi dans les régions y compris
dans le sud du pays est-ce que la crise
économique importante et la pauvreté
est-ce qu'elle nourrit aussi se
soulèvement maintenant ça n'est plus que
les jeunes et ça n'est plus que au fond
les
urbains cultivés instruits tout à fait
parce que il faut pas oublier que cette
colère des femmes et bien c'est enfin
s'explique dans un contexte déjà de
marasme économique crise économique très
importante entre 50 et 80% de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
l'ensemble des trois pouvoirs sont aux
mains des ultras conservateurs qui ne
laissent absolument plus de place aux
gens de
respirer en même temps que j'ai beaucoup
parlé de la Thalie banalisation de
pouvoir et depuis que les ultrasons
arrivent au pouvoir on voit que en fait
les droits des femmes sont davantage
bafoués déjà parce qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à prendre confiance de
l'oppression sur le corps des femmes en
Iran elles ne peuvent pas danser chanter
écouter de la musique racontez-nous et
elles ne peuvent pas chanter toute seule
elles peuvent chanter encore mais pas
toute seule bien évidemment elle peut
pas danser si par exemple elle joue dans
les pièces de théâtre il faut qu'elle
cache vraiment leur féminité on va dire
en même temps que vous savez les femmes
iraniennes je vous donne un exemple nous
donne plus naissance qu'à 1,6 enfants
c'est à dire moins qu'en France
elles sont très instruites on voit que
la plupart des 4 millions d'étudiants
des universités sont des étudiantes des
lycéens etc et ça aussi bien dans les
villages que dans les villes raison pour
laquelle l'écart entre les villes et
villages a beaucoup diminué et 75 % de
la population iranienne est urbaine et
donc même les villageois moi j'ai
beaucoup fait des enquêtes dans les
villages aussi
aspirent on met valeur que les gens
voilà à quoi assistent ton dans ce pays
une révolution non vous dites le mot ça
n'est pas qu'une révolte de plus c'est
une révolution en cours vous savez les
révolutions il s'agit d'un processus
pour les révolutions ça n'arrive pas du
jour au lendemain à renverser un pouvoir
à faire un changement mais ce que je
constate c'est déjà une révolution
culturelle c'est une révolution qui
demande un changement profond à la fois
de pouvoir mais également des
franchement culturel important les
jeunes qui sont dans la rue sont aussi
là pour revendiquer les droits égaux la
liberté l'égalité des droits à la fin de
la théocratie absolument et la fin de
l'islam politique et donc ce qui se
passe en Iran je pense est très
important et raison pour laquelle il
faut que ça puisse continuer il faut que
les médias puissent aussi continuer à en
parler parce que si ce mouvement
triomphe et je pense que ça va être le
cas parce que je ne vois pas la majorité
de cette société qui est constituée de
jeunes revendicatif va se remettre à ce
pouvoir moyenâgeux et répressif pour
avoir des conséquences dans l'ensemble
dans la rue du monde de l'islam
politique et et aussi en Occident aussi
parce que c'est un mouvement aussi
contre surtout je dirais contre le
l'islam politique et contre aussi c'est
préceptes donc c'est très important ce
qui se passe à l'heure actuelle on lit
sur les slogans va très loin les
manifestants vides directement le guide
suprême tout-puissant à lire soleil ce
même guide qui est sorti de son silence
en expliquant que ce mouvement était
récupéré ou qu'il fallait y voir la main
des Américains ou des ou des Israéliens
derrière est-ce qu'il est déstabilisé
est-ce qu'il peut tomber écouter
l'origine dans son ensemble y compris le
guide sont et sérieusement ils ont peur
parce que comme je vous le disais ça
n'est plus seulement les classes
moyennes les intellectuels les jeunes
ils se déplacent moyenne supérieurs mais
aussi des jeunes issus des classes
populaires c'est à dire cela même dont
les parents soutenaient encore le régime
il y a 10 ans qui sont aussi dans la rue
et donc leurs parents avec donc le
régime se sait illégitime et donc
ébranlé et ils ont peur et c'est pour ça
que ils répriment davantage on voit que
la répression est croissante alors pour
l'instant les forces armées n'ont pas
encore changé de camp mais je pense que
si le mouvement continue parce que nous
avons aussi l'expérience de la
révolution de 79 ça peut basculer
comment soutenir de l'extérieur c'est la
grande question ici même à l'Assemblée
dans l'hémicycle il y a eu une minute de
silence à l'initiative de Yaël Braun
Pivet on le voit partout dans le monde
aussi les manifestations se multiplient
on le voit à Paris à Tokyo à Montréal on
le voit encore à Chypre il y a même la
Turquie et puis la société civile
s'organise vous avez sans doute vu ce
clip aujourd'hui d'actrice de grandes
actrices françaises qui se coupent une
mèche de cheveux on va on va le voir
comme l'on fait d'ailleurs les
Iraniennes ce geste d'ailleurs
expliquez-nous ce geste c'est un geste
traditionnel voilà qui existe dans la
mythologie Perse et lorsqu'il y a un
problème lorsqu'il y a un deuil à mort
etc bah les femmes avaient l'habitude de
se couper les cheveux en signe de deuil
et donc voilà mais il y a un deuil et
une renaissance bien sûr aussi
en même temps que alors pour répondre à
votre question tout ça c'est à quel
poids tous ces soutiens alors le soutien
moral est symbolique est très important
je pense que les Iraniens iraniennes
iraniennes qui contestent à l'intérieur
du pays
sont vraiment prennent de pouvoir en
pensant que ils sont il est elles sont
soutenus ça ne suffit pas vous savez il
y a des mesures à entreprendre par
exemple des sanctions ciblées contre les
donneurs d'ordre ceux qui répriment
leurs enfants à l'étranger les enfants
leurs enfants l'étranger les 5000
enfants de ces mots-là qui sont à
l'étranger qui profitent de l'argent de
pétrole mais en même temps de la liberté
de la démocratie
sur la population
entre quarantaine de sanctions
ciblés contre ces gens là et contre
leurs enfants qui aussi ont pillé la
richesse nationale alors même que en
Iran ils sont en train de tuer les
enfants qui sont dans la rue donc il
faut que l'Europe aussi dit prennent des
mesures sérieuses alors je sais que on
va peut-être pas les appeler des
sanctions mais des restrictions qu'on me
dirait Monsieur Joseph Morel mais en
tout cas c'est ça que demande aussi les
Iraniens iraniens vous avez d'ailleurs
rencontré la présidente de la Commission
européenne pour ceux la VAN DER laenne
donc non j'ai rencontré la présidente du
Parlement du Parlement européen
pardonnez-moi il y a évidemment cette
négociation en cours sur le nucléaire
iranien vous appelez les responsables
politiques européens à tenir compte dans
ces négociations de ce qui se passe en
Iran et de peser sur ces négociations
absolument parce que on a besoin que eux
ils signent le DCP mais en même temps
les Iraniens ont besoin de l'Europe ne
l'oublions pas ils ont besoin leur
pétrole plus tard ils ont bossé besoin
de la technologie européenne donc
l'Europe ne doit pas se dire démuni de
moyens de pression l'Europe a beaucoup
beaucoup de moyens de pression
merci beaucoup vous restez avec moi à
zadekian je rappelle le titre de votre
livre femme et pouvoir en Islam c'est à
dire aux éditions Michel on restait avec
moi je suis sûr que certains des parties
pris de nos affranchis ce soir vont vous
faire réagir on va accueillir ce soir
les chamboncelles pour sa carte blanche
qui va revenir sur la question du voile
et la manière dont les féministes se
divisent en France sur le sujet
Jean-Rémy Baudot pour la politique les
féministes vont-elles créer leur propre
parti politique après les affaires
Bailly catenens qui secouent la gauche
et puis Fanny Guy nochet pour l'économie
réformer les droits de succession la
promesse du candidat Macron divise la
majorité et nos affranchis les voici
bonsoir à vous trois on va commencer par
votre carte blanche les hormoncelles
port du voile que les femmes décident
seuls vous ne vous nous dites ce soir la
question du voile on vient d'en parler
en Iran elle est selon vous mal utilisé
en France oui je pense et surtout
toute chose il faut dire en introduction
qu'il faut cesser de contrôler le corps
des femmes on veut les forcer à le
porter dans certains pays les empêcher
de le porter dans d'autres depuis de
nombreuses années le voile est sur
toutes les bouches et plus
particulièrement sur celle des
responsables politiques qui adorent
stigmatiser ce petit bout de tissu
notamment en période électorale période
pendant lesquelles la question de son
interdiction plus récente dans l'espace
public revient toujours sur le devant de
la scène alors deux camps s'opposent de
quand s'oppose effectivement il est
courant de voir quand même globalement
sur les plateaux de télévision remplis
d'hommes blancs en train de disserter
pendant des heures sur la nécessité de
l'interdire compte tenu de la menace
qu'il représente à leurs yeux sans
jamais mais alors vraiment jamais
demander la vie des premières
intéressées et ce n'est pas que les
hommes effectivement qui aiment se
saisir de ce sujet car même dans les
milieux féministes le voile partage et
dérange alors les universalistes d'un
côté les néo féministes de l'autre alors
je dirais plutôt les universalistes vs
les intersectionnelles oui les
féministes dit universalistes
effectivement considèrent le considère
vraiment comme étant le symbole par
excellence de la dénomination masculine
quand d'autres dans le camp des
intersectionnels considère plutôt que
les intéressés ont elles seules le droit
de décider ce qu'elles peuvent faire ou
non et donc il regarde par ailleurs et
malheureusement c'est pas une question
toute neuve alors ce n'est absolument
pas une question toute neuve
effectivement parce que souvenez-vous
quand les femmes n'avaient pas le droit
de porter de pantalon par exemple c'est
interdiction date de
1800 pardon et pour autant et ça va
peut-être vous étonner ça a été abrogé
en France que en 2013 dans un autre
registre encore une fois l'interdiction
de recourir à des interruptions
volontaires de grossesse s'inscrit
également dans la volonté de contrôler
le corps des femmes mais pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce que cette question du
voile cristallise autant les tensions et
fait couler autant d'encre en France et
de son aujourd'hui en Iran je n'ai pas
vraiment la réponse mais ce que je peux
vous dire ce soir en tout cas et
peut-être que cela pourra apporter
quelques aimants de réflexion c'est que
n'importe où dans le monde le corps des
femmes fait l'objet d'injonction et très
souvent ce sont des hommes qui décident
et légifèrent pour dire aux femmes ce
qu'elles ont droit de faire ou non avec
leur corps et ce soir moi j'ai envie de
dire que il est peut-être temps
d'arrêter avec cela il faudrait que ça
cesse que ce soit en France en Iran aux
États-Unis ou ailleurs il faut que les
femmes puissent décider pour elles-mêmes
et par elle-même de ce qu'elles
entendent faire ou non avec leur corps
comment vous réalisez cette à cette
chronique ça va je suis tout à fait
d'accord mais bon la problématique de
voile en Iran il faut pas oublier c'est
un voile obligatoire qui a été imposé
par un islam politique par le pouvoir
islamiste donc ce qui n'est absolument
pas le cas en France donc il faut
vraiment faire cette distinction là et
ce que revendique les femmes iraniennes
c'est pas contre le voile ni contre
l'islam c'est contre l'islam politique
et ses précepts mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous il faut laisser les
femmes libres de leur choix absolument
un objet d'asservissement de la femme le
vois pas parce que dans ce livre j'ai un
gros chapitre sur le voile tout au long
de l'histoire de l'Islam je ne le pense
pas non
alors on va continuer à parler des
femmes avec vous jean-y Baudot et des
féministes qui restent très sous le choc
de l'affaire Catena c'est Bayou vous
nous dites ce soir et si les féministes
s'organisaient en politiquement avec un
parti alors on vient de parler
effectivement du voile avec lia et la
liberté de le porter ou pas et en fait
il y a un sous-titre à ce débat dans Léa
nous parler à l'instant c'est que c'est
l'un des sujets qui fracture le
féminisme en France avec la question de
la prostitution et les transsexuels
notamment c'est l'un des clivages qui
provoque le plus de tension alors c'est
clivage ils sont soit sous forme de
débat idéologique il peut y avoir aussi
des tensions réelles on a vu par exemple
Sandrine Rousseau être sifflé ce
week-end lors de la manifestation de
soutien aux iraniennes certaines
féministes la juge complaisante avec les
islamistes sur la question du vol en
France mais ça va parfois plus loin sur
d'autres sujets une féministe historique
me confiait par exemple hier qu'elle
avait été agressée lors d'une
manifestation par d'autres féministes G2
et menaces d'oeuf pardon j'ai 9 et une
menace de mort pardon évidemment à cause
de ces positions sur les transsexuels la
violence quand le débat est impossible
dans ces conditions comment faire du
féminisme une force politique rassembler
car oui certains le souhaitent comme le
disait une responsable d'un collectif
nos luttes ne sont bien portés que par
nous-mêmes LFI et elev ont souvent été
perdu comme des parties capables de
porter leur revendications féministes
mais les récentes affaires dont vous
dont vous parliez et surtout la réaction
de certains cas comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon
on en a déjà parlé tout ça ça a jeté un
doute est-ce que c'est parti sont
réellement féministes d'où cette idée
éventuellement d'avoir un étranger par
exemple en Belgique depuis les années 70
il y en a en Suède il y en a récemment
en Espagne en France rien au-delà de
mouvement réellement plutôt associatif
l'éco féminisme plus radical et ce qui
pourra aller chercher un autre électorat
politiquement ça s'entend électoralement
c'est pas dit j'en ai parlé à des
sondeurs pour l'instant ça n'est pas
réellement testé mais le risque en fait
c'est segmenter l'offre politique sur la
base d'une radicalité sectorielle et de
finir à si j'étais un peu taquin 1,5%
comme comme Lutte Ouvrière donc la
question c'est peut-être est-ce que les
féministes sont plus utiles aujourd'hui
dans les parties c'est ce que pense
beaucoup d'entre elles quand même les
parties sont jugées comme des structures
patriarcales qui aboutissent trop
souvent à réduire le rôle des femmes la
lutte se justifie sans rapport de force
interne rien ne changera me confier une
élu élevé c'est une stratégie qui
évidemment ne plaît pas à tout le monde
elle se servent de l'écologie comme un
coucou s'agace un cadre écologiste qui
s'envoient d'un bon œil qui puisse y
avoir une scission ce qui est certain
c'est par exemple chez les écologistes
il y aura un congrès dans quelques
semaines ça pourrait clarifier la ligne
et qu'en fonction des résultats on
pourrait revoir ou pas et bien des
vérités d'indépendance des éco
féministes
de la tête un parti féministe c'est très
intéressant
féministe en non-mexique je pense qu'il
vaut mieux des hommes féministes que les
femmes non féministes ou antiféministes
ça clairement donc peut-être pas en nous
mixité effectivement mais c'est très
intéressant parce qu'en fait c'est ça
qu'on voit que la question de savoir
est-ce que le féminisme est un combat
politique est-ce qu'il est perçu en
France aujourd'hui comme un pont combat
politique donc ça aboutit effectivement
à pourquoi pas une structuration de
manière partisane mais aussi de savoir
comment montrer que c'était un combat
bien sûr de là en faire un parti 100% à
la question c'est de savoir
exclusivement consacré à cette cause
pour ton les luttes en fait c'est comme
au sein du mouvement politique comment
on passe de revendications à des
politiques publiques éventuellement dans
un système français qui repose
essentiellement sur les parties
ces débats français non mais lesquels
féministe parce que on parle de
féministe qu'on s'y avait un seul
féminisme il y a des féminismes et cela
m'étonnerait fort que qu'elle puisse se
réunir au sein d'un même parti ou alors
il y aura 36000 fractions différentes et
bon on va pas aboutir à grand chose
on l'a vu encore vraiment comment vous
avez vécu cette manifestation avec
Sandrine Rousseau est-ce qu'elle avait
sa place dans cette manifestation elle a
été elle avait sa place comme tous les
autres qui sont venus qui se sont
déplacés qui sont venus pour soutenir le
combat des femmes iranienne sauf que il
faut pas mélanger avec ce que je disais
ou instrumentaliser le combat des
iraniennes pour à des fins
électoralistes ou à des fins de pouvoir
politique en France c'est d'autres
dossiers différents le voile peut être
un objet d'embellissement quand même la
tenue c'est propos là sur ce plateau
alors objet d'embellissement je ne suis
pas sûr quand même j'irai pas jusque là
c'est une question
n'est pas voilé sans personne ce n'est
pas musulmane que je sache et donc il
faut pas aller il faut pas être plus
chaud que le bol non plus mais je pense
que effectivement tout ça c'est aussi il
y a des causes politiques vous le vous
le savez à tout ça en tout cas en ce qui
me concerne je ne pense pas qu'il faille
mélanger ou ainsi instrumentaliser les
luttes des femmes iraniennes contre le
voile obligatoire avec des enjeux
politiques
alors on va quitter le terrain des
femmes quoique on va parler succession
avec vous Fanny cette question de des
droits de succession revient dans le
débat à la faveur d'un amendement c'est
Aurore berger la patronne du groupe
Renaissance qui remet le sujet sur la
table en proposant d'alléger les droits
de succession un sujet qui est plus ou
moins
urticant au sein même de la majorité qui
vend même parce que à gauche
traditionnellement on est pour taxer
davantage les droits de succession les
patrimoines alors qu'à droite c'est
plutôt le contraire on est plutôt pour
alléger ses droits et c'est vrai qu'au
sein du macronisme bien cette amendement
donc on parlait a fait tout un pataquès
parce que il n'y a pas de ligne claire
il n'y en a pas parce que le chef
lui-même n'en a pas défini si vous
prenez le macronisme de 2017 et bien
l'héritage c'est la rente c'est ce
contre quoi il faut lutter et donc il
faut taxer plus les droits de succession
on rappelle que quand même 60% des
patrimoines en France viennent de
l'héritage donc c'est une façon
d'améliorer l'égalité de donc ça c'est
Macron 2017 mais 2022 alors là ça change
complètement c'est le contraire il faut
au contraire alléger les droits de
succession parce qu'il faut s'adapter au
prix de l'immobilier c'est souvent la
première chose que l'on transmet c'est
un patrimoine immobilier comme les prix
ont beaucoup augmenté et bien on
augmente l'abattement et puis on ouvre
aussi on s'adapte à la société on ouvre
les transmissions à une famille plus
élargie entre les neveux les nièces les
tentes les ongles tout ça évidemment
cette proposition elle est faite
souvenez-vous dans un contexte électoral
où il s'agit de siphonner les voix à
droite et c'est vrai que dans un
contexte de pouvoir d'achat et bien ça
plaît plutôt aux Français alors sur le
fond le macronisme n'a jamais vraiment
tranché et bien non et encore
aujourd'hui et bien cet amendement du
coup d'avoir berger apparaît comme très
opportuniste parce qu'on est quand même
à un moment où on discute le budget ou à
l'Assemblée où on essaye de capter les
voix de la droite alors sachant que
budgétairement une réforme un allégement
un allègement des droits de succession
ces 3 milliards d'euros et d'ailleurs
Gabriel Attal le ministre des comptes
publics a dit tout de suite voilà on
arrête on a mieux à faire aujourd'hui
que de se priver de 3 milliards d'euros
dans les caisses on a d'autres priorités
donc on va pas le faire tout de suite et
puis ça pose une question aussi entre
les générations parce que finalement
alléger les droits de succession ça
profiterait plutôt à un public plus âgé
si tentait que à 55 ans puisque c'est
l'âge ou habituellement en moyenne on
reçoit un héritage en France désormais
et bien ce serait plutôt eux qui
seraient favorisés donc ça pose des
questions aussi entre génération donc
cet amendement finalement on va pas
passer et bien non alors c'est un
amendement qui de toute façon était
dessiné à ouvrir les bandes en tout cas
il va pas passer pour
2023 pour le budget 2021 amendement
d'appel on a fait voilà moi j'ai
découvert ce terme vous vous connaissez
ouvrir la discussion mais pour ne pas
être appliqué tout de suite j'aurais mis
Bono pas surpris par la tentative
d'Aurore berger ce qui est compliqué
effectivement c'est de définir une ligne
précise on a vu que sur un certain
nombre de sujets le macronisme en tout
cas Emmanuel Macron pouvait changer
dessus de un peu un peu David donc c'est
très bien dit c'est très bien dit par
Fanny ce soir
ça rappelle que finalement la République
en marche et ce qui est désormais
Renaissance à une colonne vertébrale
idéologique assez souple effectivement
pas très rigide effectivement merci
beaucoup merci les affranchis à la
semaine prochaine et merci beaucoup à
zadécane d'être venu sur le plateau de
LCP femme et pouvoir en Islam c'est chez
Michelon et puis si vous vous demandez
pourquoi j'ai ce petit pin's c'est le
pasteur dont LCP et partenaire faites un
don sur pasteurdon.fr où en appelant le
36 20 très belle soirée documentaire
avec Jean-Pierre Garcia bien sûr à
demain
[Musique]